cough welcome back to the geek Jenna
Julien podcast cough scott we just start
off your scarf don't cough in scott at
the same time that is rude it's pretty
fun have you ever talked about the fact
that people have like found are
interesting I'm like wait a minute you
guys didn't make this cuz it's like a
YouTube library yeah welcome back to the
podcast guys this week we have our
wonderful sponsor of me and these guys
it's the only I ever wear micro little
fabric three times softer than cotton
cool designs each month and shipped
right to your door guys there's really
no reason for you not to try me on this
if you haven't it's okay that you're
late to the party you can still get in
alright we're happy to have you come on
into the me andis party just just show
up okay
and right now first-time buyers get 15%
off their first pair immunity's when
they use me undies comm slash Jenna
Julian or click the link below treat
yourself to some you need y'all and
while you're at it why don't you order
some post mates get some delivered I'm
getting food delivered to your house
that you normally can't get delivered I
mean this is a groundbreaking concept
that's done so well it's providing
delivery to the places that don't want
to do the delivery themselves and they
do it in such an efficient way post
minutes is the app that 24 hours a day
365 days a year
they'll bring you whatever you want
within an hour mmm it's wonderful okay
and right now we're giving you $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days when you go into the app and use
code Jana Julian that is post mates
thank you thank you thank you sponsors
there's a good sponsors oh yes love Eric
sound like a dream team huh dream team
you can order post these in Yomi undies
then you live in the dream why are you
looking at that is that that is what I
do every day
Wendy's anywhere to post it wait hold on
question did you pick out that lipstick
when we were shopping for the dog yeah
yeah cuz I was just getting a bunch of
random stuff so that we could have
choices sure I had thrown out like
almost all of my makeup I realized I had
thrown out like you know when you're
moving so you get rid of stuff that you
don't need or like that's just you've
put off like organizing
going through all of your stuff till you
move so while I was doing like my
bathroom and my makeup and stuff I
realized that every like piece of makeup
that I own is like five years old like
very old with the exception of the stuff
that I use like on a daily basis you
know like I would buy like you know a
lipstick or like a lip gloss here and
there but like it really wasn't going
out and getting new [ __ ] all the time so
I was like it all needs to get tossed
like it's expired
what's the shelf life like average it's
it differs I think but like you know
something's old and you've been using it
a lot or like it you can open it in like
you can see that like the consistency of
something is like dried out or like all
of my stuff is like that like why am i
holding on to this what's wrong with me
so when I went to shoot the video with
the dogs picking on my makeup I was like
they're gonna have one thing yeah so we
took a nice healthy trip over to Alta
old is okay honestly I just mean healthy
in that we were there for a while yeah I
still like is it is it controversial to
say that I think I prefer Sephora to
Alta why would that be controversial is
there something wrong with support no I
don't know just like more expensive or
something I don't even think that I just
think that they have a better selection
of stuff yeah I I've spent many many
hours in Sephora and only a few in Ulta
so my comparison is really unfair but
yeah that's a cute color though I like
it like that
did you like having the dogs pick your
makeup today today surprise thank you
they're so cute they are cute they just
like melt my heart like Marvel has been
so cute the last few days he's been
attacking you man
no he has it he has never attacked me
what's wrong with you joke joke you like
sometimes when I wake up in the morning
I look at him and he looks like a puppy
to me like he looks like a baby and it
just oh man it [ __ ] melts my heart
he really has a way of like being cute
and sweet because yeah cuz it's not like
it's not like really has to do anything
to be sweet or have that effect
he was just when he looks at you and he
just kind of is you know you can get
anything he wants from me like you know
he just like cuts me down to my core I
love when he gets in his moods though
cuz then he just like super predictable
yeah like like sometimes he'll just get
these moods where he's like furiously
excited to go to a different room and
it's not even like nighttime or bedtime
or anything like that he's just like
ready to go he did that to me today
after I did my radio show like if he
thinks that I'm gonna walk over turns
the couch like just not go with him yes
with him he'll start full-out sprinting
like not one of his feet is on the
ground he's sprinting that fast like at
one point his entire body is airborne in
the air he's so excited it's the
contrast that makes it so extreme
because the rest of the time he's very
even-keeled and then he'll just snap you
know have a weird like that time he
jumped off the bed that did not make any
sense how he landed that how he just did
it I don't get any of what was he doing
he snapped the other day like recently
and we were both just [ __ ] dying yes
he just like you know you guys have a
pretty good idea of like the pace that
Marvel moves at in life in general so
when you see him all of a sudden just
like [ __ ] lose it and like get really
excited about stuff is very funny
yeah I think I didn't know you could
move that fast he's like rubbing his
face into the carpet right now what do
you want but you talked about what you
did to my neck here Julian I don't know
what you're talking about that is a lie
this is embarrassing I don't want to
talk about her oh you don't want to talk
about it so last night was the 4th of
July we had so much fun like James yes
it was Julian's brother and sister
brother and sister and step-brother it
came over and we played cranium and hung
out and we were like you know drinking
some wine and hanging out having a good
time and we had an impromptu dance party
in the living room like I literally have
a bruise on my knees yeah you were
getting it you're getting it yeah but so
we were hanging out Julian
and Julian gave me not one but two
hickeys on either side of like you can't
even really see it but like I woke up
this morning looks like kind of drunk
I woke up this morning I was like
julienne like how [ __ ] old are you
what's wrong with you audience I don't
first of all I don't know what's wrong
with me
second of all I was feeling no no I was
saying this to you earlier like it's not
this is we're talking about I just I
don't know why I did it like five years
into the relationship I decide to give
you a hickey like why now and why I
don't understand what my decision-making
was I don't understand like how it
happened I just remember you were
showing off your dancing bruises this
morning and I look at your neck and I
can swear if she got dancing bruises on
her neck oh my god I do that because I
like you I don't ever remember ever
giving someone thank you like yeah ever
like so it's so weird that that happened
it's just not something that you like
ever consciously or like yeah yeah I'm
gonna do this boy a hickey like that's
so infinite like I hate you
you're the worst yeah yeah good job
covering it up though babe I did like I
am I'd concealer on it like earlier
today but like there's not really
anything they're not that bad it's just
like sort of a joke but it's really very
funny that you [ __ ] I'm 31 years old
and I have two hickeys right now like
what the hell dog dude I don't know what
what that's all dogs pretty odd if you
ask me that that that that happened I
don't know where I'm gonna get you back
when you lease it [ __ ] I'm gonna have
like a [ __ ] presentation of some sort
we're gonna have a hickey off in the
coming years
just wait a hickey off yeah try to give
the other person a hickey when it's the
least convenient for their life that is
that's actually a good game that should
be a game show really I would do then I
would say I wouldn't watch the proposal
I would watch that picky picky off pick
hickey off it's just a weird thing like
it's a weird thing that
that I thought I wanna stop talking
about I don't know what happened
you're a real [ __ ] mmm
depends on who you ask oh you're you
were telling me oh yeah well that's
still depends on who you ask
some people really enjoy me others would
probably like to call me a little [ __ ]
can you talk about the Bachelorette I
want to talk about that last episode
that we watched where that guy Chris
that guy makes me so uncomfortable when
he walked it over and his peacoat all
the way in the dark he's gone now I know
sorry but at this one we yeah several
weeks removed hey guys we're recording
in advance look at us we have our [ __ ]
together Hong Kong well actually by the
time just talked about the Bachelorette
last week on it yeah I just won't talk
about that guy Chris though okay we
don't have to talk about it long call
fine I just don't understand it's it's
weird like every season there's always
that one person who just somehow it is
like unaware that there's other people
there just like it's so bad at being
around other people and his his person
his interpersonal skills just make me
frustrated because I've like you know
you've met people like that but it's not
even like you being the heel either it's
not even like you're being cool about it
you're just a difficult guy and I don't
like it maybe he doesn't have to work
with people like maybe he has a job
where he just gets to be by himself yeah
yeah I mean I yeah not okay that's the
end of that no that's all I wanted to
say I just don't enjoy him I'm sorry I
don't think anyone really did though
they yeah but at the same time it's like
you know editing only does so much yeah
so like we said we're we're did double
time this week we did two of everything
like I'm genuinely so tired today after
my radio show I like you get that you
know you have no control over it like
even if you don't want to sleep like
your body's shutting off right now and
you gonna sleep you know mm-hmm that's
what happened and I fell asleep for a
little while yeah cuz I'm just I'm
beyond tired at this point yeah I mean
it's
crazy it's been a [ __ ] crazy week if
you think about it because it's
technically started with a 24 hour
stream and then right like because that
was the probably the worst timing for
that stream yeah we went from the 24
weeks worth it to time yeah but we did I
mean we recorded two of your videos we
this is our second podcast that we're
doing and we did videos in like a matter
of four days yeah but it's I mean it's
like at the end of the day we have to
like read on a plane in a couple days
yeah well I mean the reasoning behind it
though chew is that we didn't know the
YouTube / internet situation in Hong
Kong and like yeah I'm sure I could do
some research we could set up a VPN or
some [ __ ] where it's like you can
you can upload like yeah imagine it's a
thing it's it's probably way easier than
we've been allowed to be totally but
like it wasn't a risk that I was willing
to take so I was like we should probably
just upload or have something done early
for my main channel but also like it's
been I don't even know like I don't
think I've ever had a trip for work or
otherwise when I haven't had to you know
make a video or do something while I was
there and it's gonna be so incredibly
nice to have this time to actually be
somewhere and not have that like looming
over me this it does take an entire day
whether you're here or you're in London
or Portugal literally I made a video in
London in Portugal in Bali in Australia
like India like literally everywhere
I've had to make a video at some point
while I'm there which you know to most
people they're like oh that's fun you
just make like a travel vlog but you
don't do that no it's also it's
stressful to upload on Wi-Fi that isn't
yours that's like hotel and just
unpredictable all of a sudden it's like
all right it's gonna be take two days to
upload and you're editing while you're
in a foreign country and you're like man
I really like you and Rome will be like
oh we're gonna go get some lunch I'm
like sick I'm gonna [ __ ] sit here
edit you know make you leave these
once-in-a-lifetime opportunities to
travel and it's gonna be really special
to not have that day you know not that
it's the worst thing in the world but to
me after all these years I think it's
gonna be real
special to not have that day on address
for sure and like it doesn t affect that
one day they were working but like you
said it kind of looms the whole trip but
you think about it the whole time and
thinking back to some of the trips we've
taken there have been some like horror
experiences with uploading videos I
remember there's been like a couple
really like tough situations with you
know like we were in Bali you're up all
night just babysitting it as uploaded 1%
every like five minutes and you're just
like sitting there because it's like the
worst Wi-Fi ever and then I remember
there were other times when like in
Australia like we we were just like
sitting and watching that thing process
and upload for hours I was looking tears
I remember one in Austria remember that
and I remember that was like you be like
me you were like because it was so late
it was like getting to the early hours
in the morning and we were both like
taking turns and I remember you like
breaking down because that had been like
you know you filmed for a couple days it
was like sort of a vlog video and then
like yeah man that [ __ ] breaks you so
it's it's absolutely it's dope that
we're gonna be able to just have a trip
and not like not really work during the
trip well I mean we're working on the
trip yeah but like not upload like I'm
working there and that's what you're
doing that trip but not having to also
make a video but I'm gonna be nice like
you know when you go and you vlog and
stuff and that's just wonderful I like I
love watching those like what you record
when we're traveling I think those are
so [ __ ] rad but like it's just it's
gonna be so nice to have a trip where my
physical presence is my job and that's
all I have to worry about you know well
yeah it's it seems like that's
sufficient enough of a workload but I'm
so excited it's gonna be really fun yeah
has any fun yeah I mean it's gonna be a
crazy wild experience to be in Hong Kong
it's already gonna be back yeah like
that's funny you're gonna be we're gonna
have landed yes two days ago that's
trippy
well anyway we you know hopefully it
went well Jenna Julian
I'm just excited because I think like
our trip to Portugal was like it's not
somewhere that I would at like when we
went to Tokyo I was like that is the
only place on my bucket list like that
is the only place that I really want to
go the rest of the world I'm like that'd
be really rad but I'm probably not gonna
save up my money and take a trip there
so yeah Tokyo I was like I'm gonna go
there no matter what no matter how some
day I will go I'm gonna make it happen
Hong Kong to me is like it's not
somewhere that I ever expected to go you
know and Portugal was like that as well
yeah I would say the same thing yeah
both of these places were very expect to
go there and I'm so down I mean it was
such a wonderful time in Portugal
Portugal was [ __ ] fantastic that's a
place that like you said I'd never would
expected to go but now that I've been
I'm like I'm gonna go back place is so
cool like beautiful romantic looking for
a bit every was so pretty it really
wasn't like a beautiful place well I
haven't been to a lot of Europe I've
been to London that's it I haven't been
to France or like Italy or Italy
yeah I've I haven't been doing any of
your up really at least [ __ ] cool man
yeah oh into Ireland yeah yeah that hey
oh yeah I loved Dublin but yeah the
thing about Dublin is we had so much fun
in the city but everyone we met was like
go outside Dublin like that's where it's
you know go outside yeah but I like oh
my god that was so fun mm-hmm yeah and
what I was saying is Italy's like I went
there when I was a lot younger but I
just it's it's a special place and I'm
like play like anytime you go somewhere
else like it Europe's romantic it's
pretty beautiful we haven't really taken
a vacation like ever we've talked about
it and then back to work yeah but that's
something I think about though like I'm
getting a little too old
you know like too old for too old for
not having a vacation you know yeah and
just like a really nice like we just
playing something and we go
not like cuz usually when we have some
free time like a weekend or like a long
weekend
we'll take the dogs and we'll drive
somewhere because to me I'm like now I
feel guilty that we have some free time
and we're not taking the dog so we don't
really go anywhere that isn't I don't
like dry it's driving this yes like a
weekend trip and we're always taking the
dogs yeah like other than that no we
don't like it would be really nice to
just go and shut off my phone for like
an entire week or something oh my god
and not have anything to do except live
my life I'd be really I haven't done
that just like be like like very very
normal like do do couple things and like
go out to dinner and like not you know
it seems like really average timing but
we actually talked about it a couple
months ago we were obviously like we
were close to like picking a date to
like go to like Hawaii or something I've
never been why yeah but then it's like
you get consumed with all these other
dates that are happening and you're just
like I can't even mentally process so
fast I feel like it's so hard sometimes
when you're just living your life and
you're like I just wish the time would
slow down like time is just happening so
fast and I wish it would just chill out
cuz I'm trying to do stuff like can you
relax
no yeah and like weeks blur in two
months blur in two years and you're like
where what it was remember that time we
were talking about go on vacation and
now it's like four years later and
you're like we just never did it you
know I know it's like you for me it's
like I you know you spend so much of
your time and your brainpower trying to
like make good decisions and be good at
your job and be good at your
relationship and like all the things
that go into being an adult and like
progressing as a human like you for me I
spend all my time that I'm awake
thinking about all of those things if
it's not one thing it's the other if
it's not work it's if it's for making
time for friends or my other projects or
you know it's a million [ __ ] things
and so after however many months and
years and then you just have a moment
where you actually think about it you're
like not that I was doing anything wrong
because you're not but like holy [ __ ]
like things just fly by and then it's
the years later and then you you're
getting older and I know this
sounds like some cliche like you know
the good times gone before you know but
um
yeah it's starting to feel more like
that especially when we're so busy like
it's hard not to but I mean that's why
I'm excited to go to Hong Kong even
though this week has been very difficult
in terms of working and doing a million
things but it's probably the closest
that we'll have to any sort of vacation
in a long time yeah yeah well nobody
good and it's over so I hope you guys oh
yeah I am gonna miss playing video games
though I do always miss playing video
games let me go out of town that's one
thing that yeah like playing video games
as an adult has been one of the most
social things that I've done in years
honestly like I've made more friends
playing online in that room downstairs
than a lot of other things yeah like
people that I like and enjoy you know
like that genuinely make me laugh that I
think are good people like I've I've
found more social interaction than like
years of going out at bars it's so true
and so much more meaningful interactions
great well it it's not like we're
sitting there and drinking every time we
play video games like it's a really nice
fun outlet and it's very social well
yeah and also if you are drinking you're
drinking with people who you've already
built a regular relationship for so it's
not like when you're in a bar you're
drunk and you're meeting strangers while
you're drunk and then that's that is the
extent of your relationship for those
people it's like we make these
friendships with all these people who we
know from other people you know friend
of a friend and it's like such a cool
community the way we make friends and
yeah it's like it's crazy to think how
social gaming is it's such a social
thing the way we do it and it's sorry I
keep taking you it's it's such a thing
that like I would have I and I do have
the hardest time in the world explaining
to my parents and even my dad who has
existed on the internet for many years
even professionally like you know and
like explaining to him that were up at
all the odd hours of the night gaming
yeah and that's a choice we're making
professionally and doing investing
ourselves
professionally into that decision is
like well explaining that part is one
thing but explaining the fact that we're
like hanging out with people and we have
friends who do it with us it's like they
don't it's hard to grasp for people who
just really is well especially like here
26 or like I'm in my 30s like I've had a
couple of my friends be genuinely
surprised because like I would dabble in
some Mario Party and like you know as
much video games as someone with like an
n64 would play you know not a ton but
like once I got into Elder Scrolls and
I'm sitting there on my [ __ ] headset
talking to my group members and we're
talking about the dungeon and [ __ ] like
you realize how nice it is and how like
it just sort of brings people together
in a way that they wouldn't be otherwise
I just I feel like it's so cool to be my
age and I'll go and turn on my computer
and be like alright I'm gonna play and
usually this would be sort of like a sad
solitary activity right like oh you're
losing your new games and we're talking
to all these people online they're just
like us like it brings you so much
closer to your friends but there is
still that like stigma or a level of
misunderstanding about that the
community aspect or the social aspect of
it yeah I would say it's a
misunderstanding more than anything it's
not even like you know it's the people
who are generally who are older like our
parents or whatever look at that scope
of things especially with like the way
for Knights blown up and the way to
which is exploding like they look at
these things and they kind of generalize
okay video games what do we associate
video games with laziness bad habits
like not doing your homework feel like
that and it's it's hard to like get
beneath the surface and really kind of
see what's going on as that person I had
an interesting conversation recently
with a buddy of mine at jujitsu buddy of
mine and he's older than me he's got a
19 year old son and so just just for
reference he has like no experience the
video games like he's just like a
40-something year old dude who's an
actor and he does Jitsu and that's how I
know and so we were talking he you know
me and one of my other buddies were
talking about
twitch and then he comes up he's like
wait a minute are you talking about I
saw some kid I don't understand what
he's saying he sounds stupid and he
obviously meant nothing bad by it he was
talking about ninja and I'll say you're
talking about ninja he's like yes that's
the one
what's the deal why do people watch and
he's just like bye be so loud he's
annoying what was and I had it like calm
I was like first I was like first of all
don't you dare comfort you're not my dad
ya know what like I obviously knowing
the guy I know he's not a bad dude I
know he's coming from a place of just
straight-up totally common misconception
people to have that attitude yeah and so
I was like you need to understand that
wow that sort of thing doesn't appeal to
a person like you right off the bat and
that's totally okay there's so much
going on beneath the surface that makes
what he's doing completely brilliant
yeah number one he's the best at the
game he's grinded for years on unpopular
games for a handful of viewers for years
and years and finally got his break
whatever but like just explaining why
video games are not just what parents
think they are anymore and why they can
be positive not just in the sense of
like a kid growing up to be a twitch
streamer like that's one route yeah but
like like we're talking about being
social playing games with your friends
meeting other friends are playing with
groups and wow it may look like you're
tucked away in the basement being
antisocial you potentially being more
social than you would be otherwise if
you're outside I feel like I've been
more social the last couple years so
we've been playing video games than I
have in a while yeah and I agree I agree
like the friends that we've made like I
was so excited to go to e3 mainly just
to meet some of our friends who have
like been internet friends with because
we've been playing games yeah like that
is a cool thing and with YouTube sure
like you know you connect with
occasionally you connect with other
youtubers because you're youtubers or
you have similar channels or whatever
you like each other shows and that's
cool and that happens and it will
forever happen but the weight which you
get to like hey let's get some games
okay and then you're like chatting with
someone for five hours right when when
at any YouTube collab do you get that
sort of with like time with someone you
you don't get any sort of quality like
and it's so funny I said because we were
playing with one of our friends Reid who
was a friend of Chaco we've been playing
with I loved read reads wonderful and I
we were gonna play we liked we were
preparing dinner and we knew that later
on the night we were in play read and I
was just thinking myself and I remember
saying I was like you know what's crazy
is like we're like later on we're just
gonna like talk to our friends for like
a lot of hours you know that's what you
do while you're gaming yeah and you're
like giving you your coms about the game
but 90% of the [ __ ] you're saying is
just conversation yeah that's so cool
well that's one of my favorite things
about pub G versus fort day anyways I'm
sorry unpopular opinion for tonight is
so wonderful it's doing so much for so
many people they're doing everything
right I just I just still like pub G a
little better that's personal choice but
like there's so much downtime and pub G
where you can just sit and have [ __ ]
small talk and like make jokes and hang
out and just be goofy like there's so
much time for tonight there's no
fast-paced there's not really that
amount of time to just shoot the [ __ ]
really like pop G games like 45 minutes
some [ __ ] times and you're like so
much of that you don't see anybody
you're not getting in a fight you just
[ __ ] digging around and it's
fantastic it's like you're camping yeah
it's out in the world with someone yeah
literally with them you are in a censor
with them mmm-hmm that's crazy
it's really fun but I really do feel
like it's been an incredible outlet for
me personally because like I was that
girl that like always went out and like
you know well especially remember we
first started dating we first are dating
yes I was like every weekend I was like
let's go out like what are you doing
let's go come on like it's Friday
why aren't we out like what are you
doing yeah literally did not because I
just I worked in nightlife for so many
years and like all my nights off it
would like I would want to go out and
like enjoy myself and like I just the
concept of staying in on the weekends
was like I'm wasting my time
remember that let's go live life I
remember that and as an adult like I got
used to hanging out with you and like
being at home on the weekends like this
is actually a really [ __ ] nice I'm
like really enjoying myself and then it
turned into like bull play video games
on the weekends at night and I'm
this is like a perfect thing for me I'm
being social and laughing of hanging out
you're the cardigan I'm at home and it
is so [ __ ] fun yeah I I went out with
you a lot because you know you wanted to
go out you know I wanted to make you
happy go to whatever bars and stuff but
I was way ahead of my time because I was
like down with hanging out at home
well you back then I never even had the
stage in my life where I wanted to just
go out all the time I did yeah you know
I had that I had moments where I did
work at night left where it was
appealing to like go you know drink
after whatever but it was never like I
never felt that urge so to speak like
the urge to order some post mates Julian
you don't feel like getting up and
leaving your online friends who you
might be gaming with post mates that's
another good thing about pub G like you
can get a post mate within one game in
pub G sometimes depends on the game
depends on the post mate but it is
possible guys post mates is the delivery
app for all of your favorite restaurants
that don't have delivery options it's it
doesn't have to be food it can be the
market it can be a drugstore you can get
stuff out in the world without being out
in the world incredibly appealing if you
ask me if you feel like having some
delicious food but you know it's across
town you don't want to sit in traffic
but you will you have time to have a
snack tide you over
make the post mate send that traffic
they want to sit in traffic for you okay
there that's what they're there for
24 hours a day guys 365 days a year post
mates will bring you whatever you want
within the hour just as long as it's not
illegal you know it's like food let's be
real here okay it's not whatever you
want but it's it's good you want a vegan
burger you want pizza you want a hot dog
you want soda they even can get like
alcohol from the grocery store you want
that they'll bring it to you guys and
for a limited time post pace is giving
you guys $100 off two lip free delivery
charge for your first seven days so it's
$100 towards your free delivery charge
okay and those little recharges add up
so that's really helpful just use code
Jenna Julian within the app guys this is
a company that DM meet during our 24
hour stream it was like hey I see you're
doing 24 hour stream here's a free tool
here's a free order on us
it's like very cool company so check
them out it's worth it because and when
you're shopping for your next pair of
underwear and you're in the store think
to yourself say hmm self why would I buy
this crappy underwear in the store when
I could get it way better and way easier
on me Andy's calm I don't know itself I
should be doing that and then run out of
the store really loud just scream while
you run out guys me undies is the most
incredible underwear you combines three
times softer than cotton so so so
comfortable they have new designs coming
out all the time and they can ship your
underwear directly to your front door
again you don't need to leave your house
these are companies that are living in
the future and they want to give you
great underwear and if you don't like a
pair it's ok you can return it and get
another pair you can have a subscription
service where you get underwear every
month or you can just buy a pair right
now they have socks they have bra that's
I don't know what you're waiting for
well you can finish watching the podcast
but when that's over then you show us
some Andy's go to meet undies combats
Emmy und IES comm / annejulien
treat yourself get 15% off plus free
shipping thank you thank you sponsors I
love these because I'll be having a good
day and I look down there they are and
I'll be having a bad day you know look
down they're still there for me always
there as long as you put them on there
they're saying meet yeah oh I want to
talk about hygiene for tonight because
we know there's some interesting things
happening oh my leg on you well you
already did it so au contraire BA can
you do that voice that you were doing
earlier today no I can't please I don't
know how to do it okay I was like he was
like gurgling you know I was like
make a reference you gotta finish the
vine are you happy
yeah well you do remember that made-up
language you were doing to are someone
Smith instable our Evelyn stip nothing
about parish has left pinch no say Kim
come on months that's me speaking
gibberish I was on a roll earlier okay
you can't just recreate that outside in
the backyard gurgling making fire hisses
and just gurgling really loud and I was
like our neighbors are gonna like call
the police dude Winston no just kind of
experimenting to figure out your next
brilliant voice character without
experimenting you know you don't have
any brilliant voice characters I have
many many many all right give us a voice
that's know ya know I'm not a puppet do
a voice do that one you just said I like
it I want to hear you say a sentence in
it it's taxing on my throat Wow
yeah be rude to the Entertainer that'll
get them to do a good job entertaining
don't boo me he's fun really fun Oh too
soon I want a refund um you're not
getting one I already took your money
and invested it when you walked into the
front no money back I paid money for
this show that there's gonna be vine
references made in a throaty no noise
mm-hmm so perform no I won't please no I
won't do the one that's like I'm washing
me in my clothes I forget where it come
you have to tip your head all the way
back yeah does gnarly honestly that's
that's like could be offensive
that's like [ __ ] wait
I've just been smoking with her life
that's just kind of where I'm where my
mind I'd like me and my clothes yeah
Mike gross I'm sorry for those of you
who are listening this with like really
good headphones on you sound like a frog
I am a frog yo soy el frog oh this
little piggy went to the store and this
little piggy went to - Trap House and
this is a biggie follow the other one in
the trap house and this little piggy I'm
gonna take my leg off you know what's a
trap house so this movie he said who
trap house I'm on some then they all got
drugs and this one ran all the way home
Wow these these four didn't run anywhere
they were beached on there but because
of all the drugs they did they had to
just don't swallow into the mic I didn't
you did hey guys welcome to the
bickering podcast where Julia and I just
sit here and bicker next time we have a
fight about something I'm just gonna
like table it it's like no so we can
have it do this on the box babe we'll
deal with this on the podcast okay all
right you don't like the way I leave my
paper towels in the counter we'll talk
about on the podcast
man what a riveting podcast listening to
a couple argue just like bickering the
podcast I mean that's essentially what
we do here anyways yes we just sit here
we pretty much just pick her I'm fine
with it though yeah you cute
so well that just you're really cute
okay
hey you're wearing shorts I am wanting
choice it was a hundred degrees out 205
wondering five degrees out today I don't
like them that's why you can't see my
legs boy I can see your legs
yeah you can they can't okay that's my
oh I don't like wearing shorts I feel
vulnerable vulnerable no looking inside
at home I'm wearing shorts meet beach so
anyway when are we gonna bring you into
a jiu-jitsu class I still want to bring
you in
being good and enjoying myself are two
different things
you-you-you don't know it yet but you
love dude it says I don't love jiu-jitsu
you don't know it yet I don't love
jiu-jitsu no the last time that I rolled
with you you just told me I couldn't do
all the things that instinctually I was
doing do I put your finger near my butt
yeah and then also take me non-stop and
then that's not those are not you
shouldn't need to resort to that
resorting to anything I'm winning I know
how to win you just they're signed upon
and jujitsu this is why is it good this
is why you'd be good though yeah I know
be good but I don't know myself letting
you wrote I would not I don't like close
contact like I never played contact
sports I just want everything no I want
everyone to get the [ __ ] away from me I
didn't play sports it required me to
touch other people like ever you learn
baby no well I actually have a lesson
coming up with you where I'm going to
teach you you Jitsu probably at some
point again maybe we should really work
on escaping bad positions
eep-eep eep-eep that's a ring for by the
way you have four stripes though at this
point I have four stripes in the blue
bowl
any day now be needy no baby wouldn't
get the purple is gonna give you a
listen baby
what is your coach do when you're like
I'm going out of town I'm not gonna come
in for a while does he call you everyday
and tell you that you're blowing it
it does he take a stripe away every day
that you're gone no none of those things
that's not even even close to it does he
just like your pictures on Instagram
okay so to remind you to come back there
is it's it's so weird like it's like any
other [ __ ] hobby right like you go to
yoga or you lift weights in the gym or
you go to a book club or whatever the
[ __ ] if you take time off or you can't
go for whatever reason like no one ever
is like how gay are you I'm gonna revoke
it's a [ __ ] hobby like you're there
for its
you're there for your whole life for
most people at least so the people who
really do it right or real but like I've
read like because there's you know I've
read like stories of like this go off
spill that tea what makes a bad
jiu-jitsu Academy there's so many things
that can make a bad you see what
pettiness no like a click eNOS coaches
just giving out black belts right and
left no well that's yes but what I was
going to say if you want me to answer
your question is too many snacks a snack
business inside their Judaism gym and
it's just a conflict of business yeah
and they lose sight of what they're
doing there every day it's exactly I
understand
how did you know all right go on I'm
listening I'll see here that was correct
also quite enough I can let that fish
know I was reading a horror story from
because like people I go on the
subreddit sometimes there's Jitsu
subreddit and people will like go on
there with like these horrible accounts
I'm trying jiu-jitsu and just going to
the worst Academy ever and one person
was like you know I took some time off
to deal with life and when I came back
like I just got this huge like yelling
at from my coach about like how if you
don't if you don't prioritize jiu-jitsu
then we're not gonna be here for you
it's just so stupid it's like the most
it's like the most ridiculous thing in
the world that's [ __ ] rude
but it's that's like your yoga
instructor like scolding you when you
have to go deal with your life and not
be there regularly
like that's how insane that is but to
answer your question about like what
makes is used to Academy bad a
cultivation of overly competitive
attitudes in the gym people who are
there for themselves who aren't there to
better their teammates or even work like
a teammate but there to you know play
really aggressively and oftentimes hurt
people there's so many jiu-jitsu
academies that are like half jiu-jitsu
half MMA academies to where for lack of
a better word people are try hards and
they are the t-tops
stop what the adding no you're not
is that I am adding um if someone hurts
you in jiu-jitsu from
do to sing are you allowed to just kick
them one time really good yeah that's
exactly how you solve it you just
escalate the fight further by
introducing some nice strikes yeah you
go [ __ ] you broke my arm
kick them in their arm mm-hmm [ __ ] you
Jared it's always Jared this playing oh
my god I haven't thought about that in
so long what a show where's the wheel
ladies and gentlemen where the [ __ ] is
the wheel abuse have you searched no in
a second season well we don't have cable
anymore so I don't think we can get
stuff on the discovery app I think it
was on the Discovery up the wheel that
was so long ago he did a podcast about
how we were watching this terrible
reality show survivalist thing where
people just got dropped in the middle of
nowhere if I'm pretty sure we like even
podcast about oh of course we did and
we're talking and some guy like kill the
baby alligator to eat it mmm the other
alligators like watching hey where's
Jared oh my god this smell like Jared
outside oh this boy Jared
that's so funny dude yeah it's it's only
got one season I don't know why that's
it's like the most I just want I
wouldn't watch it I was me and Jared I
would watch a second season
instantaneously isn't like it wasn't the
premise of the show that they win
nothing it's just for like yeah yes it
was literally like just to prove to TV
and yourselves that you can do this so
the nuttiest now went on because who the
[ __ ] gonna do that for nothing
five people exactly but that's what made
it so that's what made it so riveting
it's cuz it's like clearly these
dedicated nuts who are just out there to
let you out there this boy in Jared they
got nothing right what do they get you
got like a backpack of stuff oh yeah
they had like a ration of food yeah for
them to eat but it was like you know
something very small and all almost all
of it was considered like
emergency fund for them walk away though
are you like starving and losing what
hit and dying slowly and you're just
like why this boy in German the caiman
oh he wasn't an alligator the caiman
turkey boy in this boy I want to find
another TV show to watch that we're like
you're finding everything to be pretty
mediocre at best until you just find a
moment in there that is pure [ __ ]
gold like the Jared moment yeah well
it's like the guy ate a caiman right in
front of the swamp of Caymans that he
just caught it at yeah it's like he's
just watching
oh no Jared oh my god I haven't had a
show like that in a while like for a
long time it was like Oak Island and I
would just sit in there and just [ __ ]
go off but how they're not finding
anything you know frustrated I am but
it's so fun when you're watching a
random show and it just says these
brilliant moments and you're like I have
no one to share this with because it's
not really a great topic of conversation
to walk into a group of your friends go
hey you guys see the wheel of what
anybody anybody yet seen the wheel of
fun discovery in a 3 a.m.
anybody know so watching everything else
this one time right this guy finds it
came in and he eats it in front of his
friends like it's just you have no one
to share that with hmm I'm glad that you
saw that yeah I watched the whole thing
it's a great show that's why you're the
best
hey don't turn away from I don't watch I
don't want yeah I'm not a footrest I
don't I want to put me I'm not a
footrest
I'm not our last podcast we got a lot of
comments about how we should watch love
island but I don't know where to find
that love anybody knows where I can
watch love island in the United States
don't I want to point leg up No
let me rest my leg on you know I'm gonna
look up a trailer love island it looks
really good wait you're just gonna watch
a trailer on the podcast what are you
doing watching the trailer Australian I
don't know are you gonna show me more
what the hell man yeah it's not really
revealing much well if anyone knows how
I can watch love I'll i'm sure there's
ways to like have you looked on itunes
no you don't even look for you well
you're not gonna get answers for a
couple weeks
why do you want to get it for the plane
ride to Hong Kong cuz this is coming out
yeah back yes
watch love island and laugh I hope it's
funny
nice hickeys Julian stop yelling
everything's gonna be fine okay
sometimes you just get a hickey about it
no you don't know what you do I don't I
don't get you to get those things magnet
it when you sleep it on the plane I'm
gonna give you a nice Hickey so you wake
up and you have to go through customs
with the Hickey like I give a [ __ ] are
you kidding me when you go through
customs you're just like tired you just
want to be done you don't even care like
that that's probably the worst time to
do it you want to do it before jujitsu
that's like yeah I would never go I
would never go in front of like my
friends really yeah be embarrassed I
would be okay yeah you feel good about
that
yeah okay yeah okay lady guys we won
nothing on our scratch tickets we pull
late today that was exciting
mm-hmm no you want a free ticket nothing
you want nothing we won one more free
ticket one more nothing
obviously being hmm mm-hmm well thank
you guys for hanging out for a semi
interesting podcast Michelle it's nice
to sit and talk to you sometimes you
know I like I like conversational
podcast I really do and I want to do
more of them I just like because I when
I listen to podcast I love that I love
just hearing them people just like go
they just see where a conversation takes
them because that's some of the most
interesting [ __ ] and relatable stuff
because it's like that's kind of what I
want to do I just want to let my brain
go and just be super hi I'm just kidding
well I forgot where I forgot where I was
I think I was at the beginning welcome
everyone to the podcast thank you guys
for putting up with our batch filming
why are you getting so low cause it's
fun and it fails God okay
we appreciate you guys being supportive
and helpful and receiving our content
nicely I think
you've received Jenna's videos
exceptionally well recently it makes us
happy but yeah we'll be back next week
with a podcast where we're actually
recording it that week of yeah but we
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]